warren buffett says bad leaders pose
biggest
risk to companies a wall street journal
story poor management is a top three
facing companies according to warren
buffett the chief executive conglomerate
berkshire hathaway said choosing the
wrong people to lead an organization
is the number one risk for businesses in
his five decades running berkshire
buffett said
he has seen a number of companies fail
from textile mills to department stores
and he suggested that a consistent
element could be found
in those failures beyond changing
consumer behavior or shifting market
forces
you get a guy or a woman in charge of it
they're
they're personable the directors like
them they don't
know what they're doing but they know
how to put on an appearance
that's the biggest single danger buffett
said very interesting
very interesting what do you think about
that major well for me it's um
it's a little dated i feel like it is
dated i feel that there are individuals
that are
way more talented and skilled even from
the appearance
perspective because as i said earlier
even from a political standpoint
it it does matter that you have
experience in
in politics but it doesn't matter if
you're not willing to be open to the
evolution of how to lead
you know people or galvanize or even win
a particular election so when it comes
to what he's specifying
that's more of a niche perspective which
drastic has drastically changed in a lot
of different industries
and um you know i get it i respect his
mind i respect the temperament of what
he's saying
but i think it's stemming from a little
resentment you know these
social media app companies have uh
they're they're being very uh what's
what's the word for it um
um there are disruptors they're this
you know and his his model is very
different and so when it's something
that you don't understand
and they didn't ask him for permission
that's what happens no different what
i'm doing i'm not asking for permission
i've chosen to exist i'm experienced
because of my mindset and what i'm
telling you that i
you know i'm experienced and we're going
to do this together so i think there is
a little resentment there
there is a little bias that's a part of
that i still respect his mind he's done
a lot of great things but evolution does
occur and it does exist
yes it does that is the truth adam what
do you think
about this specific leadership question
or just the leadership question
we talked about this like who's hosting
the oscars like the who's the face of
the brand
um the person at top does matter like
the ceo does need to drive a company i
mean you would have the best perspective
on this i think
more than anyone right you being as a
ceo leading the field
leading the sales force leading your
entire company
i think that that's essentially his his
point here i mean
i i'm more to be honest with you more
intrigued by the
the 10 key takeaways which is probably
the next story we're going with
you know what why don't we go to the
story of uh california taxes why don't
we talk about that before we go into the
takeaways because i think that's uh
can i give you one question sure buffalo
you know it's ironic i think that he's
talking about executive leadership ceo
leadership because
i think there's he's punched some holes
in his own leadership right now i think
he skews old now
i think he hurt his brand excuse me well
i mean no but i mean come on yeah
seriously
he's a hundred he's 90 yeah but you know
what you and i of course but i mean
never in the past has he come across
this grumpy old guy for sure
and the other thing that kind of creeped
into his messaging is arrogance to me
i take arrogance out of that and for
someone as brilliant as the oracle of
omaha
warren buffett he missed a great
opportunity he should have been speaking
to these kids
that invest on robin hood and try to
bring them into his fold and say hey
you know good job maybe you could come
over and do some things in berkshire
hathaway we got a platform for you too
it's not
it seems like he's a supper club owner
right he needs to have a little happy
hour
thrown onto that menu right just lighten
up and loosen up those are some of the
takeaways that i i want to touch i know
how to move but you know what they
remind me of him in charlie monger you
see the muppets and the two old guys
up in the uh in the audience like oh you
idiot muppets down there
yeah but but let me let me read this
story and then we'll get into the page
of that so same page page five
when asked about people leaving
california because of taxes and a high
cost of living
mr munger said he thought state
governments were making a mistake and
allowing residents to be
wooed elsewhere i do think it is stupid
for states to drive
out their wealthiest citizens mr munger
said the old people don't commit any
crimes they donate to local charity
who in the hell in the right mind would
drive out the rich people florida and
places like that
are very shrewd and places like
california are being very
stupid that's monger do you agree i
agree
okay tell us why i agree i mean when you
look at the top
you know five percent one percent they
add so much value that a lot of people
don't take credit for or give them
credit for
uh they are the ones who uh you know
donate to foundations they are the ones
who give back they are the ones who
um you know employ you know thousands if
not millions of individuals and provide
those opportunities
um i i don't this i don't agree with the
culture that we're in now the eat the
rich culture
uh you know i don't believe that looking
at someone like you you know that's
successful and being
becoming envious of that i look at you
and i get inspired and then i start to
try to dig and see how you did it or if
i get a chance to meet you like i have
now
asked you you know what did you do or
what are your what is your insight so a
lot of people don't think that way so
i would encourage people to change that
mindset when it comes to that and why
punish them you know this is a
successful model here in florida right
you know they
they are very shrewd when it comes to
how they receive that and they want to
retain those individuals
and you should want to rule people to to
stay because that's tax revenue that's
going to help infrastructure
it's going to help the you know the
economy grow you know you know what
these guys are remind me of by the way
great point he's making with monk
why would you want to lose your
wealthiest people yeah what do they do
like do they even have the energy to go
commit a crime they got money
they're going to spend money they're
going to buy stuff they're going to
reinvest in the community they're going
to hey we need a million dollars to
build a church bringing a million
dollars for the school
here you go here's a half a million
here's 100 why would you want to lose
these guys
there is no logic in wanting to lose
your wealthiest people who are typically
your oldest people that you have in your
community because it takes a while to
compound interest
right create that why would you want to
lose them yeah i was a little
underwhelmed by his comment to be honest
with you because i just thought it was
so obvious
i mean i i would rather hear from him
maybe some solutions or some other ideas
but
it's because these governors are so
short-sighted all they think about is
tax revenue right and you know they're
going to create and
they don't they're not they have no
vision so all they can go back to their
imagination
all they can thinking about is what can
i do to have someone like me the next
day i'll just give them more money or
we'll come up with a new camp
or a government aid program or something
so there's that just the lack of
inspiration from these guys is just
demoralizing so let me just go through
the 10 key takeaways and
let's process it together so these are
the tanky takeaways
from buffett and charlie munger at the
berkshire hathaway's 2021 shareholder
meeting this is a story by
nasdaq i'll just say the main uh a point
of what it is and then we'll go process
it together number one stock market
leadership is fleeting
number two buffett and monger disagree
on s p 500 versus
berkshire hathaway meaning buffett said
i've never recommended berkshire to any
anybody as he has always wanted to avoid
any appearances of given any inside tip
on the stock
of the company he runs but monger has a
different view he says i personally
prefer holding berkshire to holding the
market he said
arguing that berkshire's set of
businesses and investment aren't
are in his view better than the average
across the market even though berkshire
hathaway has not beat the s p 500 the
last decade by the way
number three buff it airlines have done
better because we sold
i love it number four a minor mistake
from buffett some have questioned why
buffett
uh trimmed a steak in uh tech giant
apple the oracle of omaha minute that
was probably a mistake charlie in his
usual low-key way
let me know it was a mistake number five
why buffett doesn't like spax
buffett express is dislike for the spac
business model specifically the
requirement for most pacs
have to find a business within two years
if you put a gun to my head and said
you've got to go buy a business within
two years
i'd buy one buffett said but it wouldn't
be much of one number six
views on the impact of low interest
rates number seven
monger on bitcoin responding to a
shareholder question about bitcoin
buffett decided to dodge the question
his motivation avoiding making the
hundreds of thousands of viewers who
owned the cryptocurrency unhappy but
monger didn't hold back he said
i hate bitcoin success okay the whole
damn development is disgusting and
contrary to the interest of civilization
number eight a buffett dig at elon musk
when asked another shareholder question
was addressed to berkshire head of
insurance business
uh asking whether he'd write an
insurance policy for tesla ceo and
spacex founder elon musk for his
proposed
missions to mars jane quickly said no
buffet
demurred however it would depend on the
premium the berkshire hathaway ceo said
and i would probably have a somewhat
different rate if elon was
on board number nine buffett on monger
smack down robin hood this one got ugly
by the way they didn't have nice things
to say about him they said
become a you know uh buffett and monger
howard were deeply critical of brooke
buffett noted that robin hood has become
a very significant part of the casino
group that's joined the stock market in
the last year and a half
monger went further it's just god-awful
that some something like that would draw
investment from civilized men and
citizens
uh decent citizens it's deeply wrong and
last but not least berkshire's dynamic
duo has learned
some lessons in the last year so adam
i've said a lot
what are your thoughts so you went down
the list i think i thought it was a
a very good breakdown shout out to kai
for doing the research and yeah this was
great
you know i feel like i've taken a whole
uh
economics class just from kai's research
so thank you
last night exactly so shout out to major
and i doing our our research but
a couple of things that that stuck out
for me from that list is number one
this gentleman named greg abel is going
to be stepping in
for uh warren buffett and charlie munger
and i thought it was a i had to write a
little lol note here and he said that
between the two people
that i was choosing from between greg
abel and
ajit what's the gentleman's name ajit
ajit jain
he went with greg because he was young
abel was 59 versus 69 i think that's
rich coming from a 90 year old
and a 98 year old we're gonna go with
the young guy here
then um their hate on bitcoin
just feels out of touch and they
probably do have some valid points don't
get me wrong if you've made a
60-year career of investing in companies
with
you know p e ratios and earnings and
leaders and and everything that a real
company
possesses and now you just have these
you know
uh digital wallet assets decentralized
cryptocurrency
i i feel like they have this opportunity
to go you know you talked about legacy
legacy what do i want my kids to be
known as
what do you want these young investors
to remember you as these sour
old dudes that hated on you or the
greatest investor of all time that kind
of gave you some wisdom
in their final days and the the i mean
business-wise it is finals easy stepping
down
but last but not least i think this is
something interesting um
regarding the smackdown on robin hood
for someone who's
such an advocate for investing and get
out there
and compound interest and buy the s p
robin hood with their flaws and
gamifying investing i can understand why
you would
maybe have some issue issues with it but
they're
allowing retail investors to get into
the market and that's something that i'm
all about is
save that money so you can start
investing and if you're getting stimulus
checks if you're sitting at home and
you're saving money because you've never
been able to
travel or spend it at the club and
you're 20 30 something years old
and you're able to start investing it
yeah you might
lose a little bit but you're going to
definitely win because you're going to
learn a lesson
especially if you buy a company like a
gamestop or an amc
or the meme stocks or whatever you're
going to learn something
so i think he seems a little out of
touch kai you're trying to say something
go ahead
yeah no i mean i think it's interesting
how um
i'd say almost sounds like you guys are
surprised in a sense the way they're
saying it is
but if you look at it that's the way
they've invested all their careers
they're value investors they're looking
for things they can understand
how much was warren buffett criticized
in the dakota boom
when he didn't invest but he said i
don't understand it i don't feel safe to
invest it so i'm not going to try to
gamble he's always the safe bet right
and especially with uh
with charlie munger coming in then it
was like all right we're going to do
we're going to invest in something that
is works
that's proven and that can run itself he
said if uh
with coca-cola if the ceo was a ham
sandwich it would still make money
right that's their whole philosophy
that's their whole way bitcoin
and cryptocurrency as far as we know
it's still all just speculation it's
just
we can't there's no there's no um forms
or
or kind of earnings that say oh this is
going to project it to earn here and
here
in many ways you can put up you can put
calculations and say
but you can also put calculations to say
otherwise so the fact that they're
against this isn't surprising in my ways
obviously they're getting older and you
can kind of argue that as well
but they've always been the hair versus
the tortoise and they've always been
slow and steady wins the race and
like with robin hood you're not betting
necessarily on the market you're picking
a stock
and it's you're getting confetti for
buying you're getting confetti for
selling
so in many ways it's going against
everything that they're against
which is or which they're not for uh
because they've always been the slow and
steady wins the race tom good good stuff
kai
you know i think you guys have handled
it you know most of the key issues here
i'm convinced that they invested in a
tequila company or they're both a little
buzzed when they were talking
because that was just so against the
grain for them being this outspoken
talking this much trash you know i
ultimately i don't know it was a great
look for them because a i admit i
screwed up on apple i mean that's kind
of a big error
that's what sticks with me you got 10
points i screwed up on apple
i don't like bitcoin i got something
with elon musk and
and robin hood sucks i mean that's
really what i got from this let me let
me ask you
how competitive do you think monger and
buffett are competitive
how competitive you think they are you
know i think warren is extremely good i
think so
i don't know anything about very you
know like ultra
super psycho competitive yeah i think
buffett is right
you're still 90 years old and you're
going ham he still has the momma
mentality okay
all right i think he's got that killer
mindset right okay so here's here's how
i see this
uh when is it good to retire in baseball
or in basketball what's it good after a
good
season when is it a good time you've
lost a step or two when you
barkley said when scrubs are beating me
that's for that's time for me to retire
right barkley said when scrubs are
beating me and i'm sitting there saying
this scrub just beat me who the hell is
he
it's time for me to get out the league
right okay i
i don't know obviously investments is a
different uh
world because you can invest a lot
longer like meaning your tenure to want
to invest maybe your tenure to play
basketball is what say 10 or 20 years
okay you're kobe 20 years
yeah i know but i'm just saying let's
say 10 or 20 years carmel is still
playing he became the 10th all-time
scorer
say he's 10 or 20 years what's your 10
year for investments
what is it 50 years 40 years there's got
to still be a tenure
what is the number so do i think maybe
10 years ago they should have retired
maybe 10 years ago they should have
replaced themselves maybe 15 years ago
they should replace themselves i don't
know
one of the hardest things to do is when
you
look at someone you know do you remember
that interview
who's the guy the boxing commentator who
he's famous for always interviewing
boxers after the fight he's looking at
mayweather and he says
but why did you hit him in the face when
he wasn't looking larry merchant
larry merchant right now very much if if
i was if i was
20 years younger i beat you or whatever
right and then
you wouldn't know i like to see you
tried mayweather i'm going back and
forth right
but you have to realize larry is sitting
there saying dude i'm 75.
but if i was 25 i would have whooped
your ass let's just say that's the
mindset because he goes back and
remembers who is 25.
think about buffett sitting there saying
who the hell are you guys i've been
going at this for freaking nine
eighty years since i was 10 years old
investing again who are you schmucks
when i went into those meetings to want
to learn about being an investment
banker
but there's there's a flaw in that
there's a weakness in it it's almost
like this
okay i had a girlfriend of mine years
ago and
she was modeling acting movies all that
other stuff i said you know you know
there's one thing you got to be very
careful with she says what i said if the
only way you get attention is your looks
when it goes away you're psychologically
going to have a meltdown
when it goes away because it's
eventually going to go away for
everybody
yeah you're going to look like this
forever just so you know that there's
gravity things work against you as you
age it's just not going to be in your
favor long term
buffet and monger are the examples to me
of a drop that gorgeous girl
that they no longer look good because
better looking girls are coming up and
they have a hard time because they no
longer get the attention that they used
to get
i may be fully wrong i may be absolutely
off base here and i'm missing it but
i think for them the route that you were
recommending fantastic route to say hey
why don't we bring these younger guys
together see what we can do why don't
you think you can do something come on
down let's create a summit and bring
them up why do you think about this
and closed doors it's not even open hey
bring the bitcoin guy anthony papliano
we just had there that he went they're
going back and forth
yeah bring some of these guys in that
they don't know nothing about what is
the future because the reality of it is
you kind of got a pivot you know you
kind of got a pivot right now ebay just
announced they're about to take uh
bitcoin matter of fact one
this was our first week ever where one
of the companies i'm hiring as a
consultant they paid as a by bitcoin wow
like do you receive i'm like yeah sure
what do we say by bitcoin i would send
a bunch of ethereum no problem people
are now going in that direction
and whether you like it or not you have
to pivot i don't know if they're doing
that
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye